right now we want to dive into the
guilty verdict in the amount arbory case
yesterday a jury convicted three men of
murder and other charges for chasing
arbury down and shooting him in
brunswick georgia last year the three
men claimed they suspected arbory of
committing burglaries in their
neighborhood and they were trying to
make a citizen's arrest well the jury
rejected that defense many saw this case
as a test of racial bias in the criminal
justice system so joining us now is
legal analyst and attorney joe tamborino
we should note that he is not affiliated
with the arbury case good morning happy
thanksgiving joe
good morning happy thanksgiving
so let me ask you all three men were
convicted of felony murder but only
travis mcmichael was convicted of malice
murder explain the difference to our
audience
well with malice that means there's a
deliberate taking of life and with
felony murder that means that you
committed a felony and that felony led
to someone's death in this case mr
arbory but everyone should understand
that the penalties are the same they're
all facing life in prison the only
difference would be
for the malice murder you could get life
without parole and it would likely be
without parole and with the felony
murder you could also get life without
parole or with parole and if the judge
gives parole they would have to serve a
minimum of 30 years
so i'm asking you to speculate here but
what do you expect the sentencing to be
i would expect for travis mcmichael who
was the person who shot and killed mr
arbory that it would be a life sentence
without parole and then i would expect
the other two greg mcmichael and roddy
bryant could face a life in prison but
with parole so they might have to do 30
years
so a lot of people uh joe they just
can't get their arms around this whole
notion of a citizen's arrest because you
know for them it just seems so odd that
that people can just walk up to someone
and and and arrest them in a way so what
is the origin of this in a place like
georgia
that's a great question because
georgia's citizens arrest law
was from
1863 that's during the civil war georgia
wasn't even technically part of the
united states at that point they were
with the confederacy so that law it took
mr arbory's death over 150 years to have
that law repealed and i think you're
going to see a lot of states going
forward re-examining citizens arrest
laws because it's very ambiguous and it
could get into serious trouble
you mentioned re-examining those laws we
also have the in this case and also in
the written house case open carry laws
were sort of put into focus do you see a
change possibly happening with those
yes we're going to see some type of
change for a couple of reasons
first every state has different open
carry laws some states require permits
or some type of license other states you
can simply carry openly but right now
with the u.s supreme court there's a
case out of new york where sometime
within the next year we will see if the
u.s supreme court expands a person's
ability and right to open carry or
restriction it's right now at the u.s
supreme court we'll probably hear
something next year
all right joe tamborina wishing you and
yours a wonderful holiday thank you very
much
thank you
and 48 hours has an in-depth look at the
case with its report a promise to ahmad
saturday night at 10 9 central right
here on cbs